قطر تستضيف كاس العالم ودول الخليج
المجاوره استعدت معها لاستضافه الجمهور
ثلاثون الف اجنبي توقعت هيئه السياحه
السعوديه استقبالهم خلال كاس العالم و 240
رحله اسبوعيا تسيرها السعوديه برا وجوا
للمشجعين للمقيمين في السعوديه 100% زياده
في اسعار حجوزات الوحدات السكنيه في مدينه
الاحساء المجاوره لقطر و 48 وحده سكنيه
متاحه حسب لجنه السياحه في غرفه الاحساء
12,000 سياره قدره منفذ سلوى الحدودي
مرورها يوميا في مده لا تستغرق اكثر من 10
دقائق
وثمان 168 رحله خليجيه تستقبلها الدوحه من
الدول الخليجيه يوميا في المونديال
واربعون رحله تستقبلها الدوحه يوميا من
مدينه دبي واحده من افضل الوجه في
المونديال 40 دقيقه الى الدوحه باجراءات
سفر مبسطه مده الرحله من دبي الى الدوحه
و13 رحله يوميا من الكويت للعاصمه القطريه
الدوحه باسعار تبدا من 200 دينار كويتي اي
حوالي 650 دولار